pour répondre à votre question 321 une
demande d'asile auront été pour
l'instant formulé depuis le 25 février
dernier de la part de personnes venant
venant d'ukraine sur les à peu près 5000
personnes que nous avons vu arriver sur
le territoire national ce les 5000
personnes que nous avons vu arriver ce
territoire national d'abord il faut bien
voir que ces chiffres de son sens du
passé du nombre de personnes qui sont en
france pour la bonne et simple raison
que d'une part ceux qui ont des
passeports biométriques scav l'essentiel
de la population de vivre pardon
ukrainiennes n'ont pas besoin de
demander de visa c'est donc ton pas
besoin de se présenter à une autorité
quelconque et donc peuvent circuler
librement dans l'espace européen raison
que la police aux frontières qui nous
fait le comptage des personnes
ukrainienne alliance au territoire
national dans les aéroports aux
frontières terrestres dans les gares j'y
reviendrai ne perçoivent que ce qu'il
voit il ya plein sans doute de personnes
qui sont passés par le territoire
national ou vont rejoindre des amis ou
une famille où une association sur le
territoire national sans pour l'instant
être capable de dire le nombre de
personnes qu'ils ont sur le territoire
national on le verra après ce qu'ils
demanderont la protection temporaire
mais pour l'instant ce ne sont que des
comptage fait par la police aux
frontières ça c'est le premier point des
gens ont pu venir ils peuvent être
installées en france au genou le
sachions pas ce qu'ils ont dans les 90
jours de leur présence sur le territoire
européen l'impossibilité de circuler
sans passeport avec l'astronaute rich
sont bizarres et puis à tout ce qui
passe par la france mais qui ne
signeraient pas parce que les
communautés ukrainiennes sont nombreuses
en italie vraiment ils passent pas par
la france pour nous on était dit quoique
on en reparlera l'espagne portugal où il
ya une forte communauté ukrainienne
également et puis en grande-bretagne
pour avoir les questions de sénateurs
j'y reviendrai
ce qui est certain c'est que
ces passages sont difficiles à compter
d'un pays à un autre mais une grande
partie d'entre eux traversent la france
sans pour autant s'y arrêter bien sûr
c'est d'autant plus vrai que les
passages sont de diverses formes
beaucoup à la frontière italo-française
notamment au péage de la turbie mais
aussi beaucoup à roissy ou un mauvais
puisque les personnes ont pris parfois
l'habitude de prendre l'avion notamment
de pologne de roumanie pour venir
directement peut-être par la route que
nous empruntions peut-être dans les
temps heureux de vacances je pense aux
vols commerciaux low cost qui vont à
l'aéroport de beauvais et arrive sur le
territoire national par par ce biais là
il ya aussi tous ceux qui viennent par
train d'autriche ou d'allemagne où
désormais aussi par car et donc on va
dire que chacun se débrouille et qu' il
est difficile pour la police française
de pouvoir suivre exactement ses
déplacements même si aujourd'hui nous
avons eu effectivement une publication
grosso modo part de monsieur présidence
qui expliqué shi différentes dimanche et
ce matin du premier ministre de façon
exponentielle et il ya peu de chances
que cela s'arrête évidemment alors
aujourd'hui nous sommes actuellement à
10500 98 places possibles pour
accueillir c'est ces personnes
ukrainienne donc on est largement au
dessus des capacités par rapport aux
personnes que nous constatons 6000
particuliers qui ont offert une présence
de familles dans les foyers français et
3700 places des collectivités locales
qui pour l'instant sont remontés au
préfet de la république nous avons écrit
dès la semaine dernière je crois que
j'ai fait parvenir aux parlementaires la
lettre que nous avons envoyé à plusieurs
ministres à tous les élus qui souhaitait
organiser
la solidarité de leur association de
leur propre commune des familles et les
maires sont en contact direct avec les
préfet mais aussi les présidents de
conseils départementaux présente
conseils régionaux pour offrir ces
places j'ai nommé à préfet le préfet y
mettre en charge la coordination de
cette de cet accueil bien évidemment et
nous apprenons tous les jours la
ministre déléguée marlène schiappa est
d'ailleurs particulièrement chargé à la
fois d'une plateforme qu'elle a mis en
place sur internet qui permet à chacune
et à chacun de se faire connaître pour
accueillir ces familles mais également
d'organiser les choses avec les
associations d'élus locaux qui ont été
reçus vendredi dernier au ministère de
l'intérieur alors si les places sont
nombreuses aujourd'hui ne corresponds
sont pas saturées au sens où le nombre
d'ukrainiens vont sans doute plus tôt
dans leur famille lorsqu'ils viennent en
france et ne comme je les lis pas tous
arrêtés en france nous voyons bien que
la saturation peut arriver notamment sur
la plaque parisienne qui est la
concentration des gens qui attendent et
bien évidemment mais aussi dans le
calaisis on y reviendra tout à l'heure
pour parler des anglais et donc je tiens
de réunions tous les deux jours place
beauvau attention des directeurs du
ministère de l'intérieur indépendamment
des conseils de défense régulier que tu
as président de la république la
question des réfugiés est évidemment
souligné et de décisions sans doute
seront proposés dès demain au conseil de
défense pour encore améliorer notre
capacité d'accueil pour faire face
effectivement soit à des phénomènes
d'augmentation de migration de réfugiés
sur le territoire national et pour les
accueillir le dignement soit pour aider
des pays qui vont connaître des
saturations pour ça la pologne on pense
aussi à la moldavie l'attak de dessin va
sans doute faire naître un exode encore
plus important en moldavie est donc
peut-être peut-être des systèmes de
relocalisation même si ce mot est sans
doute mal approprié pour le cas pour le
cas précis ici
[Musique]